problema número 81 ya es igual a 248
menos 398 por equis cuál de los
siguientes valores de x da el valor más
grande de la ecuación anterior bueno de
esta ecuación que nos dan ye igual a 248
menos
- 398 x
esta parte de acá que es la que tiene el
término de x es la que podría afectar
qué tan grande o qué tan pequeño podría
llegar a ser yo y lo que sucede es que
esto se resta a 248 para tener el valor
de al máximo esto que se resta no
debemos minimizar o de ser posible
multiplicarlo por un número negativo así
en lugar de restar se sumaría 248 y
aumentaría el valor de ella y de hecho
en las opciones vemos que hay un número
negativo hay un -1 que es nuestra opción
porque si yo sustituyó este menos uno de
la opción y aquí esto va a ser igual a
menos -1 por 398 va a ser menos 398
menos por menos
esto va a ser un más se suma y eso es
igual a 646 y aquí restamos un negativo
que fue mejor que restar un 0 muy bien
pasamos al siguiente problema la máquina
produce tornillos a una tasa uniforme de
120 tornillos por 40 segundos y la
máquina benz produce tornillos a una
tasa uniforme de 100 tornillos cada 20
segundos si las dos máquinas funcionan
simultáneamente cuántos segundos
tardarán en producir un total de 200
tornillos bueno nos dicen que la máquina
a produce 120 tornillos de este tornillo
aunque puede confundirse con tiempo pero
aquí va a ser tornillos entre 40
segundos
y esto es de la máquina de la máquina
nos están diciendo que produce 100
tornillos entre o por 20 segundos cada
20 segundos esto 120 entre 40 es lo
mismo que tener tres tornillos por
segundo y esto de 100 entre 20 es igual
a 5
tornillos cada segundo
si las dos van a ser trabajando al mismo
tiempo estos se van a sumar y vamos a
tener que combinar habrá una tasa de
ocho tornillos cada segundo cada segundo
y nos preguntan cuánto tardan en
producirse 200 tornillos bueno vamos a
dividir 200 entre 8 haciendo analogía a
esta fórmula de la distancia es igual a
la rapidez por el tiempo aquí te es
tiempo no tornillos aquí es tiempo y
podemos hacer como les digo una analogía
con la producción podemos decir que la
producción va a ser igual a la rapidez
en la que se producen las cosas por el
tiempo en el que se realiza esta
actividad así que el tiempo de aquí el
tiempo va a ser igual a la producción
entre la rapidez
les recomiendo normalmente aplicar
fórmulas porque si esto es para
mostrarles que se pueden hacer analogías
útiles para ayudarnos con el
razonamiento esto lo sustituimos que la
producción es de 200 tornillos lo que
queremos saber
la rapidez o la tasa es de ocho
tornillos a quite es de tornillos no se
confundan con tiempo ocho tornillos por
segundo esto es igual a 200 entre 8 y
aquí trabajamos con las unidades
tornillos por como esto está dividiendo
pasa multiplicando su complemento
segundos entre tornillos aquí los
tornillos se van nos queda la unidad de
segundos de tiempo que es bueno porque
la unidad que nos interesa y nos queda
que el tiempo que se tarda va a ser
igual a 200 entre 8 es igual a 25
segundos
es nuestra opción ve veamos el siguiente
problema
número 83 cuál es el equivalente decimal
de un quinto elevado a la quinta
potencia pensemos en un quinto como en
un decimal un quinto es igual a 0.2 que
está elevado a la quinta potencia quinta
potencia este 5 nos entiende es un 5 ok
vamos a calcular esto bueno la forma que
se me ocurre es poner 0.2 x 0.2 es igual
a 2 por 24 tenemos aquí un lugar a la
derecha del punto decimal y aquí también
por lo que en la multiplicación va a ser
dos lugares a la izquierda punto 04 este
punto 04 lo multiplicó a su vez por otro
punto 2
4 x 280 y aquí 123 lugares a la derecha
del punto decimal por lo que vamos a
tener que mover esto 1 2 3 lugares el
punto punto 008 aquí va aquí es la
tercera potencia el estoy elevando al
cubo tercera potencia
punto 2
esto lo multiplicó a su vez por punto 2
de nuevo punto 2
lo multiplicó 8 por 2 16 2 por 0 0
y tenemos 1 2 3 4 lugares a la derecha
del punto por lo que recorremos este
punto uno dos tres cuatro lugares punto
0 016 esta es la cuarta potencia esto ya
lo tengo que multiplicar una vez más
punto 16 por punto 2
esto es igual a 3200 uno dos tres cuatro
cinco lugares a la derecha recorremos el
punto cinco lugares a la izquierda
adiós
bueno medio chueco pero aquí está punto
0 0 0 32
esta es la respuesta esta es la quinta
potencia de punto dos quinta potencia
y es la opción
forma más sencilla de pensar en esto es
decir dos a las quinta potencia es igual
a 32 y con esto hubiera sido suficiente
porque de las opciones sólo hay una que
tiene un 32 detrás del punto decimal
cada vez que agregamos una potencia el
punto decimal se va a mover un lugar
hacia la izquierda
si tenemos aquí cinco potencias o bueno
una potencia de 5 de ese 32 que bueno
esto no es un 2 debe hacer un punto 2 ok
entonces bueno ahí te quitamos este
punto 2 para no confundir para el punto
2 elevado a las 5 tendremos que recorrer
puntos 5 lugares aquí está mi punto
decimal lo voy a recorrer 1 2 3 4 5
lugares y obviamente esto lo tengo que
rellenar con ceros y me queda punto 0 0
0 32 como este resultado que obtuve aquí
que es la misma respuesta
aquí lo hice de la manera de larga
debemos el siguiente problema problema
número 84 90 menos 8 por 20 entre 4
entre un medio es igual a bueno vamos a
hacer esta 20 entre 45 8 por 5 es 40
entonces tenemos 90 menos 40 entre un
medio
90 - 40 es igual a 50 entre un medio
esto es igual a 50 50 por el complemento
de este que es 2 entre 150 por 2 es
igual a 100 y esta es mi opción c
siguiente problema número 85 un vendedor
originalmente compró 100 baterías
iguales con un costo total de cv y los
vendió 50% más caros que el precio
original en cuanto vendió cada batería
bueno nos dicen que el costo total
va a ser igual a la cantidad de baterías
que se compró por el precio de cada una
que lo vamos a llamarse 100 baterías por
lo que pagó por cada una el precio de
venta que yo voy a llamar leve es 50%
más que el costo original entonces ve es
igual a 1.5 por el costo original
eso es el precio de venta de cada
batería y nos preguntan en términos de q
cuando se vendió cada batería el costo
en términos de q vamos a despejar esto
el costo de aquí
es igual aquí entre 100
ahora estás en este costo lo vamos a
sustituir aquí y me va a quedar que esto
es igual a 1.5 por q entre 100
y para ahorrarme estos cálculos para
hacerlos más sencillos voy a multiplicar
por 2 numerador y denominador nos va a
quedar que esto es igual a 3 entre 200
por q
es mi opción
el siguiente problema
número 86 una secuencia que se
incrementa de 10 es de los consecutivos
la suma de los cinco primeros enteros de
560 cuál es la suma de los últimos cinco
enteros
no está diciendo que son enteros
consecutivos no sé cuáles son a mi
primer entero le voy a llamar x
el siguiente como es consecutivo pues va
a ser x + 1 el siguiente va a ser igual
a x2
y me está diciendo que la suma de los
tres primeros números consecutivos que
llega hasta x + 4
1 2 3 4 5 la zona de éstos
me debe dar 560 si yo sumo esto va a ser
4 37 29 110 esto es 10
1 2 3 4 5 x x se ve no sé cuánto vale
no voy a poner todavía despejar esto voy
a dejarlo aquí un momento y ahora voy a
resolver la última parte que me dicen
cuánto es la suma de los cinco últimos
enteros los siguientes cinco números van
a ser x + 5
y más x 6 x 7 esto los voy a sumar al
final x + 8
x 9
éstos siguen siendo 5 x 5 x ok si sumo
esto va a darme 35
35 y bueno aquí me decían que este 5 x
10 5 x más y es ahora sí que regresando
a esta parte anterior era igual a 560
si yo dejo 5x restó 10 en ambos lados me
va a quedar 550 hasta aquí le dejo no
voy a despejar x porque aquí que cree en
este 5x pues es igual a 5x de aquí
entonces esto lo sustituyó y me va a
quedar 550 más 35 va a ser igual a 585
585 que es mi opción
ok aquí el chiste era darse cuenta de
que no teníamos que encontrar el valor
de x sino que este 5x lo podríamos
utilizar de nuevo en esta otra forma y
así pues ahorrarnos un paso y ahorrarnos
tiempo nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo